le 78 de ce 15 janvier qui se poursuit
tout à l'heure sur le plateau nous
parlerons aussi du travail d'une
association à boisarcy qui travaille
donc auprès de la Maison d'Arrêt sur la
ville qui travaille auprès des familles
de détenu auparavant la chronique de
l'environnement chaque mardi avec
Valérie oribau bonsoir Valérie bonsoir
alfri et ce soir nous allons parler
produits local avec Romain Novac
président de montpanier local que vous
avez créé en avril der
donc vous vous récoltez des produits
locaux auprès des des agriculteurs des
des Yvelines pour livrer au sein des
entreprises des collectivités de
Saint-Quentin mais aussi des
particuliers alors pour mieux comprendre
nous vous avons suivi lors de cette
livraison un reportage de Johanna
boucker et Patrick Jacques de dixmud
roman no est le créateur de montagier
local basé à Épernon il se rend chez
Pascal lecock un producteur de fois gras
de basinville pour récupérer ses
commandes hebdomadaires PASC ça ça va et
toi ça va ça va je chercher des magret
aujourd'hui magr fr je crois h h une
petite dizaineord et des Ries de au FO
canard d'accord mon panier local c'est
un site internet qui ne propose à la
vente que des produits locaux dans sa
camionnette romain transporte des fruits
et légumes du pain des brioches et des
produit laitiers l'offre est varié 30 %
de nos clients sont les entreprises donc
soit des comités d'entreprise soit des
gens qui sont allés directement sur le
site et qui ont mis l'adresse de leur
société comme livraison et 70 % ce sont
surtout les particuliers qu'on livre
essentiellement le samedi ou les soirs
de semaine comme le mardi ou le vendredi
le service existe depuis le 1er avril
dernier le client fait son panier parmis
un large choix sur le site la commande
est sans engagement le montant minimum
d'e livraison est de 20 € à domicile et
de 15 € pour les entreprises le panier
coûte en moyenne 30 € par personne avec
mon panier local les producteurs peuvent
connaître laave de leur clientèle et
s'adapter aux demandes c'est une
expérience intéressante c'est un
monsieur qui veut vraiment vendre des
produits de la région donc nous on
préfère travailler en direct comme ça
que avec des passer par des revendeurs
multiples et nombreux là c'est direct
lui vient chercher les produits les
livres et on a vu qu'il s'était bien
équipé il a un camion froid et cetera
donc il fait vraiment le nécessaire pour
que les conditions soient réunies comme
c'est totalement libre on commande ce
qu'on veut au rythme où on veut c'est
pas comme un abonnement dans d'autres
dans les AMAP ou des autres choses mon
panier local enregistre 250 à 500
commandes par
mois et nous allons continuer à parler
de cette initiative avec le fondateur de
cette société en plateau oui absolument
et on entendait dans le sujet 70 % de de
vos clients sont des particulers ça ça
démarre fort ouais tout à fait c'est les
particuliers qu' ont permis justement le
le lancement du site c'est les premiers
qui ont été touchés par par le concept
les premiers qui ont adhéré donc c'est
eux que j'ai commencé à livrer dans un
premier temps en tant qu'ut entrepreneur
surtout le samedi et en voyant que ça
marchait auprès d'eux je me suis dit que
bah j'allais aussi aller voir les
entreprises là où ils sont la journée
d'autant plus que l'intérêt des
entreprises c'est que ils sont plusieurs
donc on peut livrer plusieurs personnes
dans un seul point de vente et c'est
plus rentable que faire tous les saut de
puce le samedi où là c'est beaucoup plus
d'énergie en terme de de transport et de
et de logistique comment vous avez eu
cette idée quel est votre parcours
peut-être un peu professionnel pour
venir à la création de cette entreprise
bah l'idée c'est que moi en premier
temps j'étais aussi consommateur de
produits locaux donc j'allais avec ma
famille voilà voir les différents
producteurs sauf que ça prend beaucoup
de temps donc je me suis dit que tout le
monde a pas le temps d'aller chez un
producteur de fromage de chèvr un
producteur de pain aller le le SEDI au
marché donc des fois on fait aussi
beaucoup de queue donc il y a beaucoup
de de système aujourd'hui avec la grande
distribution ils sont mis à faire
livraison à domic V courses et les
courses pour les autres aussi voilà
maintenant je suis mes courses je fais
les courses pour pour les gens c'est
vrai que l'intérêt aussi c'est que je me
suis rendu compte que dans le dans le
département des ivelines on avait
beaucoup de producteurs et c'est vrai
que le premier que j'ai découvert
c'était la brasserie de laav Chevreuse
donc un producteur de de bière alors
voilà bière bio de la Chevreuse on sait
pas on Nimagine pas forcément qu'on a un
producteur de de biè dans dans la région
su t parce qu'on a déjà fait des
reportages et alors ce sont des P qui
sont remplis de de produits laitiers de
légumes de fruits de pain comment ça se
décline l'intérêt du du concept c'est
effectivement qu'il y a pas de panier
imposé ce sont les les gens qui
composent eux-mêmes leur panier sans
engagement donc comme les une cliente
qui qui dis ça ou il y a pas de contrat
d'adhésion je voulais que les gens ils
aient une certaine liberté de
consommation donc ils peuvent acheter
une semaine revenir la semaine d'après
ou un mois plus tard c'est vraiment
comme bon leur semble et il y a pas non
plus de comment dire de de de contrainte
voilà c'est c'est totalement totalement
libre a quand on livre en entreprise on
limite les les frais les frais de
livraison à domicile c'est 2,50 € donc
on on essaie que ça soit aussi
compétitif pour les gens puisque le but
c'est qu'il commande chaque semaine et
que ça soit pas un budget la pour un
Pier voilà pour un Pier moyen de voilà
de combien euh les paniers moyens sont
un peu plus importants quand c'est livré
à domicile peut-être que les gens
justement il il disent bah ça arrive
directement donc ça va plus facilement
dans dans le dans le frigo la moyenne
c'est quand même un panier moyen de 30 €
gens voilà le panier moyen que que je
constate c'est c'est ça alors pour 30 €
on a quoi bah pour 30 € ça dépend ce que
vous consommez mais c'est vrai que la
plupart du temps les gens vont prendre
ce que j'appelle les produits du
quotidien donc surtout les fruits et
légumes le pain les produits laitiers on
va dire les yaourts et après quand ils
veulent se faire plaisir ils peuvent
prendre la biè bio de la veille
Chevreuse des des plats cuisinés au
confit de canard comme on a vu il y a un
montant minimum pour passer une commande
comment ça se passe alors le montant
minimum de la livraison à domicile il
est de 20 € donc avec 2 € €50 de frais
de livraison et par contre les gens
peuvent se faire livrer en
entreprise pour un minimum de 15 € et
ils peuvent se faire livrer même si on a
pas forcément d'accord avec les comités
d'entreprise aujourd'hui on des
entreprises avec qui on a négocié des
des jours et des hires de livraision
bien précis mais n'importe qui qui veut
se faire livrer en entreprise peut dire
bah voilà voici l'adresse de ma société
s'il y a pas de restriction en terme
d'accès on les livre et généralement sur
la bas sur sur 5quentin c'est en fin de
semaine c'est le jeudi et et le vendredi
et on choisit ces produits son panier sa
composition sur le le site c'est ça de
l'entreprise voilà tout à fait je
voulais en fait quelque chose d'un peu
différent de ce qui existe aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup de choses qui existent
aujourd'hui en terme de paniier composés
de paniers qu'on peut récupérer en garde
les AMAP aussi qui qui soutiennent les
agriculteurs locaux moi je voulais
quelque chose de plus libre en fait qui
correspondait plus à mon mode de
consommation c'estàd que moi j'aimais
bien les les paniers de fruits et
légumes mais je voulais pas voilà que ça
soit contraignant donc les gens
composent vraiment leurs panier vont sur
le site
monpanier-local.fr ils composent
eux-mêmes leur panier en mettant ce qu'
veulent dedans fruits et légumes de
saison pain et brioches produits
laitiers fromage de chef fromage de
vache et et des bocau locaux et comme
sils achetai des DVD sur internet ils
confirment leur commande chacun se crée
un compte et par défaut on livre à
domicile le samedi s'il veulent être
livré en semaine et qu'ils ont des
horaires aussi un petit peu plus on va
dire Flexi par exemple la journée on
peut s'arranger avec eux il suffit qu'il
nous précise dans les commentaires qu'il
soitent livrer la semaine et on essaie
que ça soit le plus flexible possible et
le plus facile pour eux de consommer des
produits locaux et alors pourquoi cette
initiat est-ce que le fait de consommer
local à côté de chez soi c'est de plus
en plus prignant c'est quelque chose qui
préoccupe les gens je pense que c'est
tendance en ce moment effectivement de
consommer local on souvent parler du du
concept locavor qui qui est venu des
États-Unis le locavor voilà le concept
du local c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est tendance en ce moment sur mon
site tous les producteurs sont sont
indiqués donc il y a des gens ils se
disent ah bah oui ce producteur là je le
connais je passe sur la route tous les
matins le fromage de chèvre tel t telle
chèvrerie mais j'y vais jamais parce que
je vais pas y aller que pour trois
fromages quoi donc je me dis bah oui
effectivement là c'est intéressant je
vais les retrouver sur mon panier local
et je vais pouir acheter mes fruits et
légumes et et autres produits locaux
quoi quel avantage pour les producteurs
justement par exemple en terme de prix
qui fixe les prix ce sont eux c'est vous
alors ce sont eux il fixent les prix
qu'ils accordent à mon panier local et
moi je fixe les prix que je mets sur le
site le concept il était viable à partir
du moment où les producteur me suivait
dans le concept et accorder aussi un
tarif plus intéressant à mon panier
local en tant que revendeur moi je fixe
tous les prix en fonction des prix
boutiques c'estàd que la plupart des
producteurs ont des boutiques à la ferme
où les gens peuvent aller donc moi même
prix alors c'est pas le même prix sur le
site moi il me fut un prix il y a un
prix boutique et nous on essaie que la
différence soit minime entre leur prix
boutique oui tout à fait bien
fonctionner en tant qu'entreprise tout à
fait il y a une marge qui en fait nous
permet qui est rétribuée par le par le
producteur et moi je mets une marge un
petit peu au-dessus que son prix
boutique mais les clients se retrouvent
en terme de de temps qui peuvent passer
à voir les différents producteurs en
terme d'essence quand on va on se
déplace tout de suite vu le prix de
l'essence ça coûte quelque chose alors
ça coûte quelque chose à mon panier
local mais moi j'ai voulu que ça soit
une charge dans la société donc pas
forcément que les frais de livraison
soient élevés mais à partir du moment où
on a 10 personnes sur la base de 50 ans
éeline ça devient rentable pour nous
puisque à 2,50 € par personne nous ça
nous rentabilise le déplacement est-ce
qu'on peut être livré le jour même en
tant que particulier comment ça se passe
si on commande le matin ou alors non il
y a des jours précis alors les produits
étantné qu'on on est en flutendu moi je
récupère les produits vraiment tous les
jours quasiment enfin surtout la fin de
semaine là on a une grosse un gros pic
d'activité les gens peuvent commander au
plus tard 48h avant la livraison donc
par défaut les gens sont livrés soit à
domicile le samedi il commandent au plus
tard le jeudi soir ou le mercredi soir
s'ils veulent du pain et des brioches
puisque souvent c'est des pains au Levin
les les producteurs ont besoin de
prévoir leur plan de production c'est
des pains qu' ont besoin de monter de
reposer mais ce qui fait aussi que c'est
des pains qui se conservent très bien 4
5 jours qui peuvent être congelés tout
ça mais sinon voilà ils peuvent
commander 2 jours avant on va aller
chercher le jour qui suit on livre Le
jour d'après une dernière question
peut-être le secteur je sais pas si on
l'a dit le bassin que que vous couvrez
alors effectivement dans le reportage on
a vu qu'on était sur Épernon le plupart
du développement de mon panier local je
l'ai vouu autour du parc naturel
régional de la vaille Chevreuse
puisqueil y a pas mal de producteurs
dans dans le parc donc la volonté ça été
de se développer surtout autour du parc
donc toute la base de bah de 50 an
Eveline donc la la zone en fait dire va
va jusqu'à Versailles on livre sur
versaill même visiné et toutes les
communes de sa-quentins en iveline
toutes les communes de sa-quentin en
iveline trap guillancour et encour enfin
vous les connaissez encore mieux que moi
et on va même jusqu'aux zulis qui est
voilà aussi une zone après et après ça
va jusqupernon et charart quoi donc
c'est toute cette grande zone là qu'on
sur laquelle on intervient merci Romain
Novac d'être venu nous présenter cette
initiative merci Valérie peut-être un
agenda pour terminer cette chronique
environ tout à fait la Maison de
l'environnement propose un compte
écologique kindour la vie aventureuse
des moutons en Islande c'est une
aventure interactive et poétique qui a
lit le ludique et l'engagement et ça se
passera le vendredi 18 janvier à 10h
puis une séance à 14h30 et le samedi 19
à 17h autre rendez-vous toujours à la
Maison de l'Environnement toujours une
randonnée entre terre et lien le samedi
19 à 14h une randonnée de de 3h on peut
prendre part à cette randonnée dès 8 ans
c'est une randonné qui couvre toutes les
terres agricoles de 51 en Yveline et du
plateau de sacely une initiative pour
couvrir les étapes de production du
grain et du blé et de déguster bah
quelques produits locaux justement les
produits locaux c'était justement la
thématique de cette chronique merci
Valérie et à mardi prochain avant de
recevoir l'association solidaire qui
intervient auprès des proches des
détenus de la maison d'arrêt de Bois
d'Arcy voici le rappel des titres de ce
15 janvier en image la situation au Mali
vous avez entendu au début d'émission le
témoignage d'Amadou kouliibali d'origine
malienne il est membre d'un collectif
pour la défense des sans papapiers un
témoignage à retrouvver dès à présent
sur notre site Internet le département
des ivblines placé depuis lundi soir en
vigilance orange à l'alerte à la neige
aura été de courte durée les saleuses
étaient en action ce mardi matin pour
pas lier le risque de verglas la neige
est annoncée à nouveau ce vendredi
Xavier Deutch est un auteur belge il a
écrit 11 l'histoire d'une petite équipe
de football flamande qui va rencontrer
l'AC Milan il était avec nous hier en
plateau jusqu'à vendredi l'auteur est
convié dans les collèges et les lycé de
l'agglomération nous l'avons rencontré à
voisin le bretonux et puis nous venons
d'en parler mon panier local un système
de vente de produits exclusivement
locaux des fruits des légumes du pain de
la viande il a été créé en avril dernier
enregistre entre 250 et 500 commandes
mensuelles interview à revoir dès demain
matin en replay sur TVfil 78.com sport
du handball féminin avec la 11e journée
des championnats de France de National 2
Montini qui recevait le Havre les images
à suivre et puis le résumé complet de
l'actualité sportive c'est aussi avec le
78 sport sur notre site Internet et puis
sur notre antenne avec une rediffusion
prévu demain 14h et une toute nouvelle
édition le lundi chaque lundi en direct
à 18h30 voici tout de suite le
rball 11e journée de championnat de
France de Nationale 2 les féminines de
Montini lebretonux recevaient le Havre
ce weekend actuel 2e du championnat
malgré une belle résistance en première
période avec un but de retard à la pause
les inimontaines ont cédé du terrain en
seconde mi-temps et se sont incliné de
peu 33 buts à 29 avec cette deuxème
défaite consécutive les joueuses de
Stéphane paysan rétrograde à la 9e place
avec 18 points prochain match à
landyampul le 19
janvier